at the absolute very beginning of
coronavirus we would sort of joke but we
weren't really fully joking that at some
point they would just try to blame obama
for coronavirus they being the trump
administration
and trumpists and of course we very
quickly realized it wasn't a joke when
they started to do it eventually
we started to hear this phrase from
donald trump the cupboards were left
bare by barack obama uh bear of what
exactly it was not ever totally clear it
was ppe
or ventilators there were no tests but
of course there was no coronavirus so
how could you have a test for it
and of course absurdity aside donald
trump did have
three years if indeed he was left bare
cupboards by barack obama which he
wasn't
he was left three years to refill those
cover
cupboards before coronavirus hit now in
reality there were 19 000 ventilators in
the national stockpile when barack obama
left office
etc etc but there were three years
during which trump could have refilled
anything that was empty
they are now going full mask off
as we would call it here is tim murtagh
or murtaugh
i'm not exactly murtaugh uh donald
trump's 2020 communications director
on cnn just blaming obama just blaming
obama for what's now going on with
coronavirus take a look
if people were saying don't wear masks
because medical professionals will need
them and there might be a shortage
it's because the national stockpile had
been depleted but that's when the
president enlisted the
the role of the private sector and got
the whole of america into the production
of masks and other ppe
and i would point out ventilators you
remember at the beginning of this entire
process
we heard an awful lot out of new york
and california and other states
about what they perceived to be a
looming shortage of ventilators
that shortage never materialized because
the president's strategic mama left
19 000 ventilators you know tim
obama left 19 000 ventilators in the
plan so you're lying
and you don't you're talking like you're
talking like it's 2017.
it's 2020 sir it is 2020.
it has been almost four years hold on a
second let's let's talk about this for a
second
so here it's ventilators and ppe which
obama didn't leave us
now of course obama did certainly leave
us ventilators
and ppe as well um
but there were three years during which
trump could have boosted those supplies
but
trump insists no one could have seen
this coming so
if no one could have seen it coming how
could you possibly blame obama
but if someone could have seen this
coming even if it's partially obama's
fault
trump had three years to get ventilators
and ppe
if he saw it coming so you can't be on
one side of that without being
on the other if no one could see it
coming then certainly
it's no more obama's fault than donald
trump's and if you could have seen it
coming
then even if obama did something wrong
trump also
did something wrong by spending three
years not
preparing for a problem that we could
have seen coming so you've got to be on
one side
or the other of that they're trying to
be on both sides so then this guy tim
murda changes tact and talks instead
about testing
and that just really didn't go well the
testing program that the president has
instituted here in this country we've
tested almost 46 million americans
and the reason and what testing program
the reason why a testing program that
the president has instituted
is because this hold on a second hold on
a second the reason why a testing
program for the coronavirus didn't it's
not a federal
program he left one of the states
because there was there was no test
listen to this there was no test for the
coronavirus because prior to this
there was no coronavirus the test had to
be invented
first so now tim tim goes to
trump-built testing because coronavirus
is new and the test had to be invented
but that's true in every country tim and
yet most other countries scaled up
testing per capita much faster
they try to pretend that this is unique
to the united states
the origin was china for every country
around the world
there were no tests for every country
around the world it's not
unique to the united states the sudden
need for testing
for a new virus was the case in every
country it was the case in south korea
and italy and taiwan and greece and
everywhere we were just one of the
slowest and this really doesn't get much
better
before it could be mass produced and
spread around the country and that's
what the president has achieved 46
million tests have been conducted in
this country
we're now testing 000 people a day
and that is a wide spread and they take
two weeks a disease that did not
previously know that according to your
ideas
hold on a second if you don't test get
the results back within five days those
tests are pointless
i mean this is a testing failure time
hold on a second and the president no it
is not it's actually a tremendous
success story we're leading the world in
testing
it's so boring that they're still doing
this
leading the world in testing we have 330
million people
the total number of tests is not super
relevant
when you think about per capita but i'm
actually going to going to say something
that i've started to say on live streams
at this point even looking at per capita
is less relevant because a lot of places
don't really need tests anymore since so
few people
have the virus and what i mean by that
is we've now for example caught up to
spain and testing per capita and we've
passed
spain in tests per capita well
spain no longer needs to do very much
testing
because they've completely flattened the
curve so of course we're passing other
countries in testing per capita now
in the last few days spain has started
to see an uptick in cases
and that's another issue that we're
seeing in a few european countries which
we're going to follow
let's watch a little bit more here 46
million tests
of americans and 800 000 tests a day
there's also improvements going on
they're allowed hold on a second they're
allowing people to now be
i can't hold on a second at a time
pretty nice job by brianna keeler there
so
if this is one of those situations where
if the facts
presented by tim murtagh were true trump
had years to replenish empty cupboards
and all of that stuff
but tim murdoch's arguments aren't even
real
because the facts are not as he
describes and this is what we're
essentially down to now
repeating the same lies over and over
again
and hoping that people are
accepting it as the truth so that donald
trump
can get himself re-elected that's what
at the core of everything that's what's
at the core of trump now carrying his
mask with him as a propaganda showpiece
all the time
this is what's at the core of trump now
saying it may get worse before it gets
better and taking a new tone and all of
this different
the the portland and chicago deployments
of troops
all the singular focus at this point for
this administration and people like tim
murdah
is just getting trump reelected in
november by any means
necessary this episode is sponsored by
blue chew one of the things i make a
priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same
fda approved ingredient as in viagra and
cialis
it can be taken day or night even on a
full stomach since it's chewable
it works twice as fast as a pill
whenever the opportunity arises
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
they're made in the usa and since
bluetooth prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all no more awkwardness
we've got a special deal for our viewers
and listeners go to bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our
promo code pacman that's p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's blue
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show